[Music]
with all the successes that you've had
given and obviously you went through
failures as well as successes throughout
your career now if you could travel back
in time and meet your younger self what
would be like
the piece of advice that you'd like to
pass on to the younger self and it
doesn't have to be one specific piece of
advice per se but it could be a couple
is there any like you know list of
lessons or
specifically that you like to pass on
there are there are
um
you know
over the years the decades now and i
look at my portfolio of companies that
have been successful and those that have
failed and that happens when you're a
venture capitalist you're not going to
get winners all the time
but 75 of my returns over the last 15
years have come from companies run by
women
now they're a wide range of different
sectors everything from technology and
wireless charging to commercial kitchens
i mean there's such a broad number of
different sectors represented here and
these women don't know each other
and so i've learned to listen to the
information and here's what i learned
one of my ceo is a woman that was
running an online wedding business where
she was basically originating about 500
million dollars worth of gifts
to brides grooms and bridesmaids and
fantastic business very profitable
partnership with paypal
and she told me you know kevin i'm gonna
make an observation for you
that you should consider
most people
during their day
spend two-thirds of their time talking
only one-third of their time listening
she said why don't you reverse it why
don't you try shutting up and listen
two-thirds of the day
and talk one-third you'll become far
more powerful you'll become far better
at investing you'll have more knowledge
of more information well guess what she
was right it's very hard for people to
shut up and listen that's what i do
these days i listen i try and garner
information i try and mitigate my risk i
try to understand each business model
the key to success that i would have
taught myself 20 years ago would have
been shut up and listen
i would have gotten where i am today
much faster because i've made plenty of
mistakes in my career by not listening
that's amazing i loved it i think it you
know it really resonates with our
audience as well uh that was really
really right right right you know
um and kevin over the years uh you know
you kind of
you know how people
in looking at shark tank used to call
you arrogant but you're just being real
with them and you're just like a numbers
guy and you're so
strict about it but now you know you are
really
uh something have changed i don't know
what exactly but
you are more reachable i would say in
terms is that true do you feel that
change within yourself over the years
now
i i would say something that i agree
with you on here um
what i've learned about you know really
great investors and great managers and
great entrepreneurs that they have a
balance in their lives it doesn't mean
they don't work 25 hours a day what it
means is for the strength of being
entrepreneurial and understanding the
numbers and leading a business with all
the hardships you're going to have and
you will have them
most of these successful people have
another side for example i recently
hired a cfo fantastic woman who started
her career as a professional dancer
ballerina she still keeps it up to this
day she still gets up at five in the
morning and practices and so that
discipline makes her a better manager
the yin and yang of of of the arts and
the chaos and the challenge of dancing
versus her role as a cfo are a perfect
match and make her far more functional
far more successful far more productive
so in my life i'm trying to pursue the
arts i'm a collector i'm a guitarist i
have a very large wine making business
and i spend time blending those wines
and i'm trying to become
you know the world's largest watch
collector and i thought i was until i
went over the united arab emirates
recently and realized i'm a nothing
burger compared to those guys but i'm
one of those people out in the watch
community that has a very very
passionate desire to to buy more
timepieces they all balance me against
that you know harsh reality of business
because i got to tell you today i'm we
have we're managing right now 34
portfolio companies
every day we have chaos in one of them
and euphoria in another every day
something great is happening every day
15 of them are being acquired and we're
adding new to we're adding two new
companies this week we're investing in
but my point is it's chaos it's complete
chaos you have no idea the outcomes and
you have to roll with the punches so to
speak and you know there's going to be a
tremendous amount of volatility and you
have to find that inner space where you
think about that guitar riff you're
playing or thinking about the wine you
were making last week you just gotta
you gotta balance the pressure you know
what i mean that's that's why i think
i'm different than i was maybe even ten
years ago five years ago
amazing amazing yeah i tuned into your
instagram lives every now and then to
watch you jam and it was just one recent
few days ago you are amazing at that
that's such a you know at your level you
even trying to
yeah i can't even imagine wow
but um
you know kevin talking about
your level right you're mr wonderful
right and here you are saying
they are a greater investor than you and
here we have like roughly you know 500 2
000 people over here that look up to you
like you know
the legend
uh
one thing at your level and this is
coming from one of my friend who has
been really successful he's been on the
forbes cover and and you know has some
certain level of success
and i asked him what's the trouble being
you and he said he can't fail you can't
fail at that level do you feel that
pressure
i do i i don't want to let my investors
down i don't want to
you know put my name out there
many people approach me about becoming
investor in their company and i'm very
very selective because
you know i want to be successful as an
investor and i i know many people follow
my investment strategies so i want to
make sure that i do my due diligence and
i understand the risks i'm getting into
uh your friend is right there is a
tremendous pressure and a lot of
scrutiny that that goes on um but
you know i believe now
and particularly over the last two years
and particularly on the journey i've
gone into on crypto and centralized
decentralized finance that there's a
direct
correlation
between social media media print media
television cable
and market capitalization so if i'm able
to help a company with my millions of
followers tell their story
explain the merits of their products and
services to millions of people
i'm helping them
and as a result we attract capital
because the more successful the company
is the easier it is and their cost of
capital goes down so my role as an
investor today has changed i i'm
selective i pick my companies and then i
tell their stories all around the world
and i tell the story because i'm an
investor i don't ask for for you know
anything more than understand the risk
but i also want people to understand the
product and the services why i invested
in it and i'm a big believer in crypto
now because of the productivity
enhancement it's going to do to
financial services the largest market on
earth
is the currency and financial services
market and there's so much promise with
all of the blockchain activity and all
of the tokens that are available and all
the ideas around
new level one level two chains the h
bars of the world the polygons the
heliums all of these where i've taken
bets and made investments because at the
end of the day and i tell people this
bitcoin is not a coin
it's software that's what it is ethereum
is software if you're willing to invest
in google and you're willing to invest
in microsoft what are you investing in
you're investing in software why
wouldn't you invest in crypto it's
software
absolutely now we'll touch on your your
stance on the cryptocurrency space down
the line a little bit
but now speaking of entrepreneurship you
once said that entrepreneurship is a
state of mind
what exactly did you do you mean by that
it's very simple
you should not
pursue entrepreneurship out of the greed
of money you will never succeed if
that's why you're becoming an
entrepreneur you will never be
successful however if you're becoming an
entrepreneur out of the
pursuit of personal freedom
you have a very very large chance of
being successful
and what i mean by that is
most of the entrepreneurs
most of the ones i meet that have been
successful
i always ask them do you remember the
moment
that you became wealthy do you remember
the moment when you just turned the
switch and all of a sudden
you were
rich
now what that means though is
the moment you had the freedom to pursue
whatever you wanted that's what wealth
is it's it's how you spend the rest of
your days you have that opportunity and
every one of them says to me no i don't
remember i don't remember the day that
happened and it was the same for me i
remember in the case of the learning
company the ten of us that were managing
that business and we'd grown it to the
largest educational software company in
the world the day after we got acquired
we went from you know guys living in
on the on the sofa with sleeping bags to
being wildly wealthy
and we all showed up in the in the
office the next morning saying what do
we do next nobody wanted to stop working
we wanted to just keep going but at that
moment
at that moment i realized wow
i'm filthy rich how did this happen
it happened because all of us were
pursuing our dream of freedom and at
that moment
you know the first thing i did was go
buy
a stratocaster a guitar that i couldn't
afford until then
and i like a camera that i wanted my
whole life things that i wanted to
pursue in my own dream of personal
freedom not because i wanted to be
flashy it was because i couldn't afford
one and now i could because i worked so
hard and that's the reason you should be
an entrepreneur to provide for your
family to provide personal freedom to do
the things in life that mean something
to you and give back money to
entrepreneurs in terms of investing or
just charities you want to work with
it's a it's a new form of freedom but
you'll find you'll be working even
harder i work harder today than i've
ever worked in my life
and after i die wherever i'm going i'm
going to keep working
i love that answer that that's that's
amazing you know
for me it was not necessarily
making money obviously that was a big
part and started like you know it was
more survival i needed money uh
obviously had like fancy taste and and
wanted to fulfill that
but then when the time came is
something was missing like you know
what was it and then go back to work
again and that's
and then an act of service came from
within
and and you know helping others you know
i thought this is just something people
in the tvs talk about like oh who have
money they're like our money is not
important uh you know
service to others is or somewhere around
that narrative
and then when you're actually in that
sport you're like oh actually that's
actually makes sense that's real
as it is so it is once your basic needs
are taken taken care of the truth is my
mother taught me something that really
became important later in my life
she was a working woman but she always
said to me don't buy a lot of stuff when
you're going to buy something make sure
it's the highest quality instead of
having you know 20 suits buy three
really good ones that are going to last
buy a good watch not a mediocre one buy
something that is meaningful to you and
when she passed away and i became the
executor of her estate
she had all these chanel jackets that
she had worked for for six months a year
to buy as a young woman that were still
in style as classics and all the women
in my family fought over them because
they were almost priceless these classic
parisian chanel you know dresses and
suits and jackets that that you know
audrey hepburn wore
they were 20 30 years old but they
become classics and these things are now
vintage
this is really something to think about
when you make an investment you're
taking money that could be invested for
the future and you're putting it into
something make sure what you're buying
goes up in value to and you can do that
you don't need to buy a lot of junk i
don't spend a lot of money but when i do
i buy something really valuable like a
watch which you know i love and my what
my wife thinks i'm crazy i have so many
watches now if i wore five a day i could
never get through them in a year so it's
crazy but i do it as an investment and
so far it's been one of my most
successful in the last two years
wow yeah i was looking at your video
with some interviewer and and it was uh
your first watch was omega i believe
right
the omega speedmaster
1975 edition that they made one of the
calibers that they were worried about
were going to space so they really
worked hard on those first models and
that those late 70 vintage pieces and
now there's a new omega speedmaster
called the snoopy which has snoopy on a
rocket ship going to the moon on the
back through the crystal and that watch
has set the brand on fire it is one of
the most collectible pieces on the world
very very hard to get
omega is going to make me a one of a
kind with a red strap for shark tank
season 14 i'll be wearing it but that
watch took off at bitcoin 2021
when somebody said to the moon on stage
wearing a snoopy and that the watch went
it went up in value a thousand percent
everybody in crypto wants one now
yeah no it's the investment um because
i got to omega a c master over here and
this i got it from my dad which he
bought it pretty much it's one of the
ones in the james bond time the iconic
blue omega
and uh he
bought it i guess back then before i was
born at like for 900 or something like
that and right now this thing is going
for like twelve thousand dollars i'm
like okay now that is some
you know good returns over there for
your 900 dollars don't don't sell that
watch you'll never get another one and
the emotional attachment to your father
right yeah yeah absolutely this is not
going this is going down to my daughter
absolutely and you know my my wife is
stealing all my watches now women are
wearing the larger dials all over the
place my fp journals absolutely my
rolexes i always see them on her wrist
and she says oh i had two links removed
and i lost them another way of just
stealing my watch that's it uh i want to
go back to a question about
entrepreneurship right
what would that one advice be like for
instance like for me 24 years old
as an entrepreneur
one thing
that i should do and should you know
pray every day on what would that one
advice be so let me let me give you um
three
uh
points that i think are very important
that i would have said you know 10 years
ago with the three points but now
there's a fourth
that are essential in you as a ceo as an
entrepreneur that you must have the
ability to do and and
and
this i've seen this over decades this is
the definition of leadership when you're
an entrepreneur and you're starting a
company
number one you have to be able to
explain your opportunity or idea in 90
seconds or less
and and why you have to be able to do
that is
people will follow you if you know where
you're going and if you can't explain in
90 seconds or less your big vision your
idea what is it what product or service
are you going to create that's so
incredible
then you'll fail
number two explain why you are the right
entrepreneur to execute on that idea
great ideas are diamond doesn't
executional skills are very very hard to
find
so what is it about you that can execute
on this plan have you done it before
have you worked for a competitor have
you failed three times now you know what
you did wrong and you get it right the
fourth time whatever it is that attaches
you to that idea is very important to be
able to explain
now number three and this is extremely
important
know your numbers
how big is the market how fast is it
growing what's your break-even analysis
how many competitors are there when is
your volume going to reduce your input
cost everything about the business model
you need to know if you don't know have
somebody with you because investors are
going to ask you that in the context of
shark tank all around the world
you get the first to write and everybody
wants to invest in you including me
and then you don't know your numbers you
deserve to burn in hell and i'll put you
there i mean you have to know your
numbers that's it now lastly and this
has happened over the last three years
consumers all around the world are
getting hip
to esg it's not just a marketing scam
anymore they want sustainability they
want companies with a mission they want
companies that give back they want
companies that understand we're all
human beings this is not a marketing
scam if you're a company that's only in
it for profits of your shareholders
you'll be shunned by consumers they want
to see that you care about other people
too now that doesn't mean you have to be
less profitable what it means is you
have to show compassion you have to give
back to the community and you have to
work under an esg mandate here in south
florida where i am now or when i go you
know anywhere in asia people care about
plastic in the ocean now they don't want
that anymore they're actually thinking
about it so they care about what you do
as a company to help sustainability
and it's the companies that are
providing those mandates in their
mission
are wildly profitable now are far more
profitable because they attract very
loyal customer bases
think about that get these four points
right
this is the essence of entrepreneurship
and leadership because you have to have
a mission in addition to being able to
operate a business with great
executional skills if you like that
video where did you see my next one
don't forget to click right over here
and subscribe